you ready for this let's do it
[Applause]
you'll keel
the Scottish back sword
known for assaulting axis positions with
his Scottish back sword drawn Mad Jack
Churchill earned his name and the
respect of his troops for his famed
exploits during World War II the back
sword first came of fashion during the
16th century and is recognized for its
basket Hilt that covers the user's hand
offering complete protection
featuring a straight and lethal single
edge the weapon was a brutal slicer and
Thruster on the battlefield especially
when wielded by Mad Jack a true wartime
hero Mad Jack eventually served as a
Commando leader helping the Allied
Forces save Europe from destruction
all right blade Smiths Captain Mad Jack
Churchill may have been mad enough to
take a back sword into Modern Combat but
what I want to know is are your swords
mad enough if called upon to kill
to that end I will deliver some killing
blows to this ballistics dummy
ability here of course you ready for
this I came here to watch you kill and
chew bubble gum and I'm out of bubble
gum all right let's do this
[Music]
do it
all right Billy first stop I really like
the way that Damascus pattern shows in
your sword
now your handle it's comfortable there
are no hot spots every cut you do with
this blade is sharp enough to cut deeply
overall your weapon will kill
thank you very much
all right Robert your turn sir are you
ready I'm ready let's do this
[Music]
thank you
foreign
Roberts talk about your back sword here
a tip very pointy thrust in easily cuts
on the way out
your handle here and it's loose it's
really wiggling in my hand but overall
sir your back sword
we'll kill thank you
blade Smiths welcome to the strength
test today I'm going to take your swords
and I'm going to clear a path through
this big block of ice I don't really
care what your swords do to the ice I
want to see what the ice does to your
swords Billy you look ready to be first
Jay I was born ready
ah
a
really nice job thank you I'm sure you
could see when I was striking that the
blade flexed all over the place and came
right back to where it was in the
beginning everything's tight
nice job thank you very much
Robert how you feeling I'm ready good
I'm ready too
God
oh no
I really don't know what to think right
now
it's right here is where it hurts feels
like something pulled watching Jay
scream out in pain like that I feel that
pain as well it's kind of catching me a
little bit back here
I hate that something that I did caused
pain to another person plus it's loose
let's see Jay stepping off the testing
floor
I'm pretty sure this is this is the this
is it for me
blade Smith send any one of our finale
competitions the way that you design
those blades to perform in our
challenges is always taken into
consideration and Robert unfortunately
your weapon has hurt our user so
severely that we had to send them to the
emergency room
your weapon has been given a vote of no
confidence and cannot move forward in
testing for that reason I have to ask
you to please leave the forge
first and foremost I hope that Jay
doesn't suffer any long-term effects of
this injury
I took my time making sure that
everything was safe on this blade so to
find out that I missed something it's
kind of devastating you know
Billy your blade is sharp deadly and
strong and you are the forge of fire
champion and that is a title that comes
with a check for ten thousand dollars
good job brother
oh I'm the forged in fire champion this
is awesome
definitely not the way that I hope to
win but I was given the privilege of
doing this for a day when I can also
honor those who have given me the
freedom to do this this has been an
amazing experience and I'm very blessed
and honored to have been a part of
a lock a bar ax
the locker bar ax was the weapon of
choice for the famed Scottish
Highlanders during the 1600s featuring a
large two foot blade affixed to a wooden
pole this pole arm was simple in its
design yet lethal on and off the
battlefield containing a pronounced hook
mounted at the tip of the shaft this
deadly weapon could unmount soldiers
from their horses with a single blow
then would brutally finish the enemy
with either the head of the ax or with
its sharp fatal Edge this medieval
weapon still sees virtual combat in
video games like Assassin's Creed Unity
alright blades bits this is the kill
test now to find out how lethal your
weapons are I will take your locker bars
and deliver killing blows on this pig
carcass
Joshua you're first you ready for this
yeah let's do it
[Music]
all right Joshua first up your blade
it's a pork Chopper on its thrust you
see the wound Channel it creates such a
big deep gash it's fun to wield it's
sharp and most importantly
we'll kill good job thank you all right
Jesse your turn you ready absolutely
let's do it
[Music]
foreign
first up your blade has the weight that
every chop into something want to keep
going it wants to keep going and going
and going to where
pretty much took me with it good chops
good cuts and more importantly
it will heal thank you all right up next
the strength test Dave
to test the strength and overall
construction of your weapons I'll be
hooking The Shield pulling it into place
and then attacking it with the blade
all right Josh you're up first you ready
oh yeah
[Music]
foreign
so first off you took a little bit of
deformation here pretty much where that
edge caught some of the studs on that
Shield
but
it's still Sharp it's really a nicely
built piece got a good look to it it's
easy to wield
everything's still solid
strong ax nicely done thank you all
right Jesse your turn you ready
absolutely
foreign
Jesse
you can see on your blade here where
you've taken a pretty good roll here and
this is sort of a roll and a chip
but
everywhere else on this blade is still
sharp nicely done thank you all right
gentlemen next up the sharpness test for
that I'll give you the Doug
this is the sugar cane slice
now to find out how sharp your weapons
are I will take your weapons and deliver
cuts across these shooting bundles
Joshua first ready for this let's do it
man let's do it
foreign
Joshua you contoured this shaft here so
that when you hold on to it you can
really tell where the edge is I really
like that overall sir your weapon is
sharp it cuts all the way through
cleanly it will cut thank you all right
Jesse your turn you ready you gotcha
foreign
all right Jesse the blade is heavy it
cuts but also you can feel the weight
behind it crush the rest of it overall
sir for this test
it will cut thank you
Josh Jesse both of you guys brought in
Finale weapons that performed incredibly
well in our tests only one of you can be
the force to fire champion and that
champion is
Josh congratulations you're the fortune
fire Champion Jesse unfortunately your
blade didn't make the cut Jesse you
brought us a fantastic weapon and this
came down to the finest of details your
weapon took a bit more damage and your
opponent's weapon was a little bit
lighter and easier to control as for
those reasons we're letting you go okay
Jesse please surrender your weapon
I came here to prove to myself that I'm
not uh you know just a backyard knife
maker and I'm ecstatic that I made it
this far
all right Josh congratulations you're
the forest and fire champion and that's
a title that comes with a check for ten
thousand dollars good job brother uh
it's amazing it's an amazing feeling
please present your blade to the judges
holy crap I'm a fortune fire champion
I'm I'm speechless
the Scottish Claymore
the Claymore was used by Scottish
mercenaries in battle from the 15th to
17th century
the weapon usually 55 inches in length
would have to be held with both hands
and Swordsmen were unable to carry a
shield symbolizing fearlessness on the
battlefield
klansmen would swing The Sword in figure
eight movements
decapitating and dismembering
adversaries Legend has it that Scottish
Knight William Wallace used a claymore
in the war for Scottish independence
this epic weapon has been immortalized
in the classic movie Braveheart
it's Miss this is the kill test the term
Claymore in Gaelic means great sword to
see how lethal your weapon is and to
test its functionality according to its
historic design I will deliver two
killing blows on this animal carcass
Scott you're up you ready ready let's do
it
oh
the moment Doug hits the pig and I hear
that thud
I'm like crap uh Scott we have a little
problem here the hardness of your blade
is a little bit on the uh flexible side
it did not even cut the carcass
so that brings into question also the
sharpness of your Edge
I think and we're pretty much done
congratulations
[Applause]
it will not kill
this is a failure
Jonathan you're up are you ready
absolutely I'm confident that I made a
good blade
the blade is hard and it's ready to cut
this is going to be spectacular
oh boy
[Music]
Jonathan we have a major blade
malfunction it did initially cut through
but then it probably hit the spine it
just exploded
I'm not completely confident that I'm
going to come out with the win here but
my blade cuts and that's more than Scots
Jonathan your blade suffered
catastrophic failure for safety reasons
we can no longer continue testing on
your blade
since both weapons have suffered
malfunctions Dave will now decide on the
best course of action to move forward
with the competition in the Viking sagas
swords broke and the song of Roland's
swords broke but bent swords can be
straightened
so we'd like to give you an opportunity
Scott to straighten that weapon so we
can take it Forward into a sharpness
test to help us determine our winner
so Scott why don't you take a moment and
straighten your weapon okay
that's as straight as it's going to get
foreign
Not only was the Claymore a battlefield
Intimidator but it was also a Scottish
symbol for physical prowess and strength
so what I'm going to do to test the edge
of your blade is I am going to cut into
this piece of sheet steel
so Scott are you ready let's do it
I've got a 50 50 shot that it's going to
do well you know I just want to see what
happens
I don't even want to watch
ah
well Scott
there's actually still an edge here
we can see what it did to the steel
should have the pig made out of steel it
probably would have got better
all in all well done thank you overall
I'm pleased this was the first time I've
ever made a blade of this size of this
complexity gentlemen this by far was our
most difficult challenge to date
congratulations you both delivered your
Scottish Claymores but there can only be
one champion
Scott
congratulations you are the forged and
fire champion thank you
thanks Jonathan unfortunately your blade
did not make the cut please surrender
your weapon
it's great man thank you sir I'll be
back
absolutely proud of myself with every
failure there is a great lesson learned
and I think I'm moving forward from here
Scott congratulations you are the forest
fire champion and you'll be receiving a
check for ten thousand dollars good job
I'd never won anything in my life this
is the first time I've ever won anything
try your best and you learn from it and
then you do it again until you perfect
it I mean even though the sword didn't
do what I wanted it's still okay I won
drinks tonight
the William Wallace sword
begin right
armed with his gigantic two-handed
Claymore William Wallace was known for
leading the Scottish Rebellion against
the English during the late 12th century
measuring in a staggering five foot four
inches tall the blade weighed less than
six pounds making it both lightweight
and long enough to deliver deadly blows
against the enemy on Horseback or on
foot
Wallace LED his troops to Victory with
his namesake sword during the famous
battle of Sterling Bridge memorialized
as a Scottish hero Wallace can be seen
wielding as iconic sword in the 1995
Blockbuster Braveheart all right blade
Smiths welcome to the Keel test to find
out what kind of lethal damage your
iconic William Wallace swords will do I
will take your sword and deliver a
lethal blows on this wildboard carcass
James you're first you ready for this
yes I am all right let's do it
all right James talking about your blade
here pocket knife it is not but this
Long Blade actually has a nice weight to
it it's wieldable with two hands
grabbing on to your handle here I get a
good grip your Edge is razor sharp it
easily punctures and has a nice draw cut
to it now cutting the carcass as you can
see it cut it in half and more
importantly sir
you'll keel thank you sir all right Lyle
your attorney sir you ready yes sir
let's do it
all right let's talk about your William
Wallace sword here it's a lighter sword
it's about a half a pound lighter your
Edge is sharp now it cut very deep on
this big carcass didn't cut it in half
but it did cut over ulcer your sword
you'll look cute thank you
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test our battering ram chop now
why would you attack a battering ram
with a sword
I don't know but we're gonna do it
anyway now remember this test is not
about what your swords do to that
battery Ram but how well they hold up
James you're up first you ready Dave I
hate this plan
got it
all right James blade is still true as
it was when we started it's comfortable
it's strong and man it held up well good
job yeah I really like hearing you talk
about it that's great
all right Lyle your turn ready I guess I
guess
hey
all right Lyle first off uh remarkable
job making a weapon this big this light
and hold up that well that that's
impressive but the issue is
we've got some loosening going on
other than that you did a great job
thank you
this is the sharpness test the foam
pillar slice now unlike the strength
this is all about how sharp your weapons
are and what they do to these foam
pillars that are wrapped in leather same
here first you ready yeah man let's go
let's do it
all right James the edge of your sword
is like cutting through it's a nice
clean cut Cuts all the way through
overall sir your weapon
it will cut
thank you all right loudly alternator
sir you ready yes sir let's do this
[Music]
all right let's talk about your sword
here
um first stop
the guard is still a little bit loose
from the strength test but when it comes
to the cuts it is a sharp edge that you
have here I did cut the leather it just
didn't cut through it's a lighter blade
thinner Edge over here but
it does cut thank you
all right gentlemen you guys both
brought us back giant William Wallace
swords that exceeded our expectations
they are the largest swords ever built
in this competition so we want to
commend you guys both for that but there
can only be one Champions competition
and today's Fortune fire Champion is
James congratulations thank you Lyle
unfortunately you just didn't make the
cut today I'm gonna have to ask you
please step off the floor thank you
James congratulations you are the forge
and fire Champion you'll be leaving here
with a check for ten thousand dollars
how does it feel pretty great yeah maybe
I'm forging fire champion
great work
feels a little surreal like maybe this
isn't real you might find out tomorrow
that this didn't really happen
the Scottish Claymore Claymore hey Joy
this massive two-handed sword was
wielded by Scottish Highlanders as early
as 1490 made famous in modern pop
culture by the film Braveheart its
impressive size and length made it a
fearsome weapon the Claymore is easily
recognizable by its Quattro foil cross
guard and angled arms due to its large
size the heavy sword was usually swung
with two hands it was so deadly it was
nicknamed the slaughter sword by the
English who faced it on the battlefield
because of its prowess that Claymore was
a Mainstay of the Scottish Army for
nearly two centuries first up is the
strength test as you can see we've
brought back a test worthy of a
Champion's blade
bullet splitting
each of your blades will be locked into
a vise then will fire a single round at
your blades to test their Edge retention
and strength if your weapons are strong
should split the bullet no problem
they're not strong well your blade could
shatter entirely
good luck Matt you're up first
[Music]
I'm feeling pretty good about my sword
it's exactly the same heat shoot I did
last time and it held up perfectly fine
three two one engage
nice
you got a couple little dimples on the
edge there just a little bit dull but
everything held up beautifully good job
Matt thank you Ben you're up are you
ready
sure let's do it got him let's get it
three two one engage
there we go
yeah that sucker just fragmented he's
got a lot more profile than a plan
foreign
the only problem I could see is uh
rubbed a little bit of your etch off did
nothing at all to the blade Edge is
still perfect thank you all right next
up is the sharpness test and I'm gonna
hand you over to Dave for that
gentlemen the Scottish Claymore as you
know was a brutal weapon on the
battlefield so to test the sharpness of
your blades I'm going to take a single
blow through both these front legs of
the horse simulated with sugar cane if
your blades are sharp they should pass
right through
Matt you're up are you ready yeah kill
the horse
[Music]
Matt this weapon is so amazingly light
and flexible as well that when I hit
there was no resistance it literally
passed right through the legs I was
through them before I knew it Well Done
Matt really well done
Ben you ready let's do it all right
let's give it a try
[Music]
stuff
he's still down yeah well Ben they cut
cleanly through the first leg kind of
bogged down on the second leg unlike
Matt and I have a feeling it's the width
of the profile up here just slowing it
down a bit
but I don't think that horse is running
ever again
basically done thank you
next up is the kill test for that I'm
going to hand you over to Doug
Smiths this is the kill test
to see how lethal your blades are I will
take your Claymore and I will try to cut
through these Pig carcasses with one
chop as you know last season both
Claymore suffered catastrophic failures
on this very test let's see how much
lethal damage your baits can do
match your up first you ready go for it
let's do this
[Music]
Matt
I love the feel of your blade it feels
very comfortable in the hands it's very
easy to maneuver it was sharp enough to
cut through
in terms of lacerating but it's just so
flexible it didn't go through
for this tester
it will not kill
I'm pissed at that Pig right now
Ben you're up next you ready hope so
let's do this
foreign
[Music]
this blade just sliced all the way
through that carcass
it's flexible
it's got a good feel to the cut
This Server
will kill thanks good job
all right blade Smiths we've given the
judges a lot to talk about we're gonna
have to go back to the forge and
deliberate we'll see you there thank you
Matt Ben welcome back the judges have
evaluated your weapons performance and
construction both of your weapons are
bulletproof they're sharp and they're
deadly but today there can only be one
forged and fire champion
Ben congratulations you are first
two-time forged and fire Champion great
job Matt I have to ask you to surrender
your Scottish Claymore
I'm a fortune fire Champion that's never
going to go away I don't feel like I
failed in this I don't feel like I'm a
loser in this or anything I just feel
like bended slightly better and that's
awesome
Ben you are our first and only two-time
forged and fire Champion we will also be
receiving that check for 10 grand your
Claymore is a thing of beauty not only
to look at but to wield
I'm a loss for words thank you very much
I am the Fortune fire champion of
champions I can't believe it the people
I was competing against are so good to
actually come out and win this thing
it's absolutely amazing